people really underestimates you know
how much time they spend searching for
the right information even more so you
know how much time they actually
continue search for whether this is the
right information so this is where in a
natural language understanding machine
reading comprehension is just going to
be so important and it's doing the work
for you and that is another thing that
is really important is that you also
want to know that as people talk about
this kind of information where is the
conversation and you add some
credibility to all this kind of
interesting topics so gone are the days
of those endless blue links but today's
search is really about the real answers
in the real perspectives and the real
conversations that's why I'm so excited
to announce today a new partnership with
Reddit we are working together to bring
relevant ready the conversations to
answer simple and bringing being
entities to Reddit so talk about that
those unique applications of AI at the
intersection of social news and the
conversations and the search let me
welcome up Alexis Ohanian co-founder of
Reddit Alexis thank you so much Harry
let me go grab a beer hello everyone
good day this is pretty exciting if you
can believe it before reddit was the
front page of the Internet it was a fun
little project that my college buddy and
I were starting in a small little
apartment in Medford Massachusetts this
was back in 2005 we just graduated we
had no idea what we were doing but we
knew enough and had people who believed
in us enough to take a chance and read
it today now has hundreds of millions of
users 340 million monthly active users
and about two years ago my co-founder
and our CEO Steve came back and it was
really instrumental in bringing him back
to get the company reset and to start
doing a lot of the things that basically
we wished we had done maybe a decade ago
reddit was sold in 2006 the kind of mass
that's now independence
and for the last two years has been
shipping a ton of code building some
really amazing partnerships and building
up a team including a very formidable BD
team a couple of whom are here who
basically took a chance on us a couple
years ago because there was no BD
process and said we want to be a part of
this we see the potential and what
you're seeing here today with this
partnership with Microsoft is actually a
really good example of just how far
we've come in actually a pretty short
time so while reddit the web site is 12
years old
reddit Inc the new entity is really only
about two three years old and we're so
proud to be announcing this partnership
here with Microsoft and Bing today so
giving you a little bit of the backstory
told you a bit about myself I'm
co-founder of Reddit and you know I've
never really understood the scale of
Reddit which I know sounds crazy I'm a
co-founder one of the original users but
I never really understood the scale of
Reddit until this partnership because
when you're in the middle of it all it's
kind of hard to really understand the
numbers behind just how many
conversations and just how many
communities exist on the reddit platform
and look if I can't navigate it or grok
it then heaven help everyone else and so
the last two and a half three years have
really been a cause for us to make
reddit more accessible to the masses if
you haven't used the read adapt I
encourage you to do so it's only a year
old if you can believe it and my wife
takes credit for having sparked it
because one of our first conversations
was her confessing to me she had no idea
what reddit was immediately doing a
search on her phone not finding an app
and thinking I was a liar but that's the
world we live in today right we very
quickly look at first
reddit didn't have a mobile presence to
speak of didn't even have a mobile
website now we do it's beautiful the
desktop is you may have seen Steve
unveil at web summit is also getting a
redesign it will look beautiful it will
look modern but every one of these are
steps toward getting this great content
in front of as many people as possible
as excessively as possible and this
partnership with Bing is helping us do
that on a whole nother level and just
some of the numbers like I said 3 or 30
million monthly active users on red
a ten point seven million posts
emissions per month it's a very active
user base 2.8 million comments per day
reddit is the one social network that is
not anti-social it's the one place where
you'll actually read the comments first
before looking at the content because
they provide so much value the reason
those comments provide so much value is
because the hundreds of millions of
users like probably many of you all
upload the good ones down vote the bad
ones and a really brilliant algorithm
that Steve came up with as a 21 year old
sorts the good from the bad and this is
a pretty remarkable thing and actually
just by a quick show of hands how are
you in the room are redditors okay if
you're using reddit right now we'll take
it personally okay thank you uploads to
all of you and also thank you for being
so brave that you're willing out
yourselves is the least productive
people in this room that is that is
impressive over a hundred and thirty
eight thousand active communities for
whatever your passion whatever your love
whether it is the Seattle Seahawks
whether it is sneakers hopefully there's
a few of you sneaker it's here you can
appreciate the off White's that I'm
wearing right now but these are the
communities whose opinions we actually
care about I don't care what my friends
from college think about shoes because
they have terrible taste I care about
what this community of people this peer
group that I care about things and isn't
that how we humans have worked all along
right people come to Reddit to see this
this breadth of different communities to
get advice to get feedback to get a
better understanding of their world and
the things they care about whether they
are shopping for beard care products yes
there are a number of beard care
communities are slash beards being one
of my favorites if you don't like beards
that's fine
they'll grow on you okay alright that's
fine or maybe or maybe you're a new
parent like I was and really really
worried because every photo every parent
I know puts on the internet is perfect
and pristine because that's the image we
want to show to the world when you're
kids screaming at 4 a.m. you're not
thinking let me take a selfie you're
thinking I need someone to commiserate
with and the dad it's community on
reddit was the place for me and for so
many more whether they need skin care
advice our size skin care of addiction
could have saved my teen years I would
have found accutane a lot faster
but it didn't exist there was no place
to go to to talk about this stuff
because these are the conversations
people can really only have on a
platform like Reddit with that scale and
so all this amazing content is sitting
there it's sitting there so much content
so engaging we average about 12 minutes
per session right this is stuff that is
highly engaging but as long as it is
just on Reddit we know that we're still
missing out on a much broader audience
that we know can benefit from it and so
when we're thinking how do we find
partners who can get us to a massive
audience and a massive mainstream reach
Bing there you go
this partnership with Microsoft is just
the beginning and we've got three big
things around the intelligent search
experience that we're unveiling today
but as I've told everyone here in the
little conversations leading up to this
this is just the start it's like I said
three big things that are gonna
integrate reddit content more directly
more beautifully more helpfully into
being search results now the first of
which ask me any things this brand is
who's probably as well-known as reddit
itself many platforms have tried to copy
the model but they've all failed the
magic is in the context a crowd-sourced
QA on its surface doesn't seem really
interesting until you put it in the
context of a community and until you can
see what happens when the science
community gets a chance to talk to an
expert like Jane Goodall and ask their
very best and very smartest questions
and they don't have to be celebrities
right one of those popular AMAs of all
time was a vacuum repairman it's true he
actually came back on recently he's now
a vacuum repair manager he got a
promotion in the last few years that's
not a joke I'm serious and it may be no
small part thanks to the reddit AMA he
spent 24 hours answering literally every
question someone could post about a
vacuum and believe me there are a lot of
fascinating questions about vacuums from
like what's the weirdest thing you've
found in a vacuum to like I have this
particular model and it makes this were
war were noise every 30 seconds right
these are conversations you won't find
anywhere else but it turns out are
actually really valuable and really
nuanced and really special and we know
that there are people whether they know
it or not who are searching for this
every day on being
but now we're providing them a
world-class experience to find it
secondly reddit content itself as well
as the responses around a Bing users
question now this is fun right we're
seeing more and more queries now phrased
as questions and part of that's the rise
of voice and part of that is just the
fact that like we're just getting used
to talking to the we're talking to the
robot and expecting a good answer the
challenge here is there's a lot of
nuance when you're asking these kinds of
open-ended questions and reddit is the
largest data set in the english-speaking
world of vetted nuanced responses the
greatest NFL play is a very different
answer depending on whether you're
asking it in New England or in Seattle
and the NFL fans that I'm talking about
so like what is so so important here is
that we have this data set we've had it
actually for a very long time it gets
bigger and bigger every day
but we ourselves are still building a
data team within Reddit just to
understand all the myriad of things we
have to worry about we needed some
partners who could bring in the heavy
lifting around artificial intelligence
who were really comfortable dealing with
a massive data set and again it came
back to Microsoft and then finally the
third thing making reddit communities
and their top content these are also
known as sub reddits more accessible to
user who runs that being query find some
results and and whether they're looking
for cute animal photos which is a great
reason or looking for cooking advice
they find a rich arresting visual look
into that community we have so many
people who visit reddit who may not even
be fully aware of how much is there
beneath the surface and having these
search results be obvious and beautiful
and visual is one more step to getting
them aware of it so we wanted to help
people find the great content on reddit
being has been such a great partner in
doing this and like I said AMAs are such
there was such low-hanging fruits one of
the things that's never been done before
that we're thrilled to be announcing
here is actually now for the first time
in Bing search results you will see
upcoming AMAs now this seems this seems
sort of obvious but it's actually
something that we've never done before
and so a very common complaint we hear
from people is oh my goodness how did I
miss fill in the blank was doing this
AMA it stuff right because if you don't
know in advance then
maybe you find out about it while it's
going on or maybe you've read about it a
day later and your friend's Facebook
page or maybe you read about it a week
later on BuzzFeed but one way or one way
or another you wish you had known in
advance and so it's really exciting we
now actually can have this as a part of
these search results so Leah Remini has
done a couple AMAs now around her
documentary series on A&E around
Scientology and so here's an example as
you'll see on the right rail Q&A with
Leah Remini upcoming date time and this
is all being pulled from reddit and so
when someone runs that query because
they heard something about her or her
documentary series they know this event
is happening they can set their alarm
they can do what they need to do to make
sure they're a part of this moment and
this is I mean a transformative thing
for us we have so many people who find
their gateways to Reddit through these
AMAs because if you haven't necessarily
heard of Reddit you've heard of that
celebrity or that influencer or that
maybe you also own a vacuum and that you
want to learn from and hear from and
this becomes a great gateway and so this
is using an example of a past AMAO or
upcoming in case you're trying to set
your calendars for it that's it's not
going to work cuz it was November 29th
but you'll see that's how it's gonna
look but then there's also the leveling
up of how pass AMAs are appearing in
search results jane goodall I was in
line she did an amazing job with an AMA
on reddit asking getting asked questions
that are the best of an audience that is
very interested in science
now you could cut this a bunch of
different ways right we see AMA is
happening across all the different
communities on reddit so the question is
she'll get there are a little different
a little more nuanced and the questions
she gets from the environment community
which are a little different some
questions she might get from the two
x-chromosomes community which are a
little different from the question she
might get from the etc.etc communities
being can handle all of this and through
robots that I don't understand and
certainly would not challenge in a game
of chess figure out what the best
results should be and present them in a
way that's digestible and accessible for
a user so you can see the QA would Jane
Goodall the top comment the top response
believe me I have heard a few times that
the current desktop version of Reddit is
a little hard to grok at first glance
these beautiful results let someone
who's running a big query find this
great content dive into it
and see the very best of what the reddit
community has to offer and and really
what the best that jane goodall and
others have to offer you'll start seeing
top AMAs in these search results you're
the best AMAs of all time I have to
admit I didn't even know I've missed
about half of these and it's been a busy
year but now they exist here with
beautiful thumbnails right up top for
anyone to come see right this is more
accessibility into the rich wealth of
Reddit content that we know is there but
isn't always the most accessible and
this is part of a much bigger rollout
for us that carousel will continue to
update and we'll continue to see the
very best of these QA results these
reddit conversations that bubble up to
the top and so prospectus from reddit
conversations are interesting right
because like I said
reddit's the one place where
conversation actually happens online and
where the best stuff as determined by
that community bubbles up and this has
been fun for me because I've revisited
moments and times by life that I didn't
think I would ever again thanks to
Reddit we have millions of users across
100,000 plus communities and they
understand nuance because it's a human
asking the question and a bunch of
humans answering it and the best stuff
being voted up this is great data for
the Bing team to start to learn what
really the best answers are for
questions that might not be the easiest
for a robot for instance how accurate is
HBO's Band of Brothers now this was
totally serendipitous when the Microsoft
team presented this to me I got really
excited Band of Brothers was the show
that Steve and I would be in John while
we were building reddit and we'd at the
end of a long work day we'd get on top
of the roof in Somerville and crack open
a couple beers and watch Band of
Brothers we obsessed over this series
it's a really really well done series
and I was a history major believe it or
not and with that history degree
I studied European history I still had
questions watching this and when I dive
onto the ask historians community on
reddit I actually have a window into the
very best historians history students
may be armchair historians imaginable
because this community actually self
curates they require citation for posts
and they can provide a really valuable
insight on a subject matter that has
shades of new
let's write a question like how accurate
is HBO's band of brothers is not a
simple binary yes right it's a well yeah
in a lot of ways it is here's what they
got right here's what they got wrong
here's the thing that's pretty disputed
and here are two different points of
view now as humans we love this
especially if you like history this is
what we relish we get to dig into this
because there are different perspectives
robots don't work so well with the
nuance unless they have this data and so
now we're seeing results that are
actually helpful and valuable and you
see trending comments and look it's it's
like I am transported back to those
history classes in school with the very
best ideas being voted up and we're
seeing the same thing the results even
around things that may seem pretty
obvious like why am i pot isn't boiling
with water now look I know if you watch
it technically it's not supposed to
turns out that is not scientific fact
but if you've tried like I have to boil
one of those huge huge I just doing a
crawfish boil you ever try to I mean you
put the filling on with water and put it
on high and you will find that it
actually takes a really long time
there's a whole community of people
frustrated wondering and asking Bing for
an answer to this and now they can
actually get really helpful results they
can get an understanding from a chemists
point of view from a science community
they can also get understanding from a
chef's point of view and maybe some
tricks to help solve that little boiling
problem this is all about presenting
that great content in a much more
accessible way to being users who may or
may not even be aware of reddit when
they're running the query because we
know this content is valuable and this
is special because we see this as a
window into to frankly help people
discover new communities they even know
they wanted to be a part of they didn't
even know they were into a hundred
thirty thousand communities means a ton
of opportunities for you to find
something that you love on reddit and
it's you know it's about cute animals
sometimes this is a window into the awe
community one of our largest featuring
lots of photos of cats and dogs and
other animals and now with this
wonderful first-class treatment when you
run when you see these results you
actually see a window in you see the
votes you see the comments you see
beautiful thumbnails you are invited
into a community now in a way that is
probably new to a lot of Internet users
because we're so used to a one-way
conversation now we're exposing them to
the magic of real real conversation on
reddit and maybe you would have gotten
confused otherwise I mean data is
beautiful on the surface seems like a
community all about saying how
attractive the Android from Star Trek is
and you grammar aficionados obviously
know that technically it should say data
are beautiful but we're not going to
nitpick the data is beautiful
communities actually the largest
community of data visualization fans of
stats fans all they do is share datasets
and visualizations all the time it's a
fabulous community now it's showing up
in context in a beautiful way to see
what the trending aspects and trending
discussions are on that community and
directly linked to reddit posts and like
I said this is mutually beneficial it's
helping us bring a whole new even
broader swath of Internet users on to
Reddit in a really useful accessible
beautiful way and then it's also going
to power Bing search results so those
continue to get better and better over
time using data that only reddit has and
that's actually thanks to a lot of you
thanks to your comments and your upvotes
we know this and so now we can share it
we can make both of our platforms better
as a result and like I said from jump
this is just the start
reddit may be 12 years old on the
internet but it's really only a few
years old as a business and the growth
and the great great success we've had in
the last few years is just the beginning
this partnership is like a like a crown
jewel for us but we're not complacent we
know we still have a lot of work to do
and we have very big ambitions and this
just scratches the surface on our
relationship with Microsoft ai and
reddit data we're also launching today
here
power bi so I've had to talk to cm O's
all over fortune 100 companies who have
been asking for a crystal ball wouldn't
we all like that to be able to get in
front of the watercooler where the
conversations the real conversations are
happening among the people who we care
most about about the things we care most
about and reddit is the place whether
you want to know what the trending
sneakers are before anyone else or I
mean I've had
countless people come up to me and just
thank me and I've asked them why and
they said are such Bitcoin and I can
only imagine it's because six years ago
they were on that community seeing all
the inertia seeing all the traction
buying an ample share of Bitcoin at a
weight cheaper price than it is today
and have benefited very generously from
it but whether you want to know the
trends for the latest cryptocurrency
that's gonna pop or whether you want to
know what makeup people are really hot
for you we'll find out on reddit first
but historically it's been really hard
you've had to actually spend lots of
time being on those communities being on
the platform and now thanks to this with
power bi we now have these business
intelligence modules to do the work for
you the robots are doing the hard stuff
and so the the trends that you want to
track the the keywords do you want to
follow any of the brand insights you
want to monitor we're letting the robots
to do that work now and so we want all
of these people to get this data so that
we can give them the crystal ball turns
out it's been on reddit for a while
we're just really grateful now to have
Microsoft to help us actually bring it
to life to actually help us build that
crystal ball and we're really lucky to
alex Remini who is our director of
business development and gnome Kaduri
was our head of data partnerships are
here and we've got a cool little booth
just around the corner so you can talk
to them you can ask them anything
regarding power bi or any of the stuff
that we've announced today but again I
can't stress enough this is just the
start and this has been an exciting two
three years now since coming back but
the next two or three are gonna be even
more amazing and I'm grateful to
Microsoft for helping be such wonderful
partners in this journey so thank you
[Applause]
it's really an exciting partnership I
just couldn't really think about it any
better win-win partnerships imagine that
you know what we can do together with
330 million in a redditor users and the
450 million being users who otherwise
it's just amazing that we can really do
to use AI to transforms that not only
that the search experience but also what
does the web in the community can all
work together so I hope you have a
chance to really try this new being
experience with all those intelligent
answer
and with perspectives and the
conversations this is a new is a new
norm as you think about the new uses
such experience